first of all nick how are you doing i
know you had an onset a little injury
but you're playing hurt today yeah yeah
a little spill
um fractured rib and some other bumps
and bruises but
i am feeling really lucky probably could
have been a little worse uh
so all is good i'm recovering nicely and
and
i feel ready for a big billboard award
weekend coming up what happened you were
riding a bike what was going what
happened
yeah riding a bike uh part you know part
of this show that we're doing olympic
dreams and and
um you know something just got caught
and
dirt on the bike and and just tumbled
but uh
again i'm i feel i feel good
surprisingly all things considered and
um you know i was back in my voice chair
right away
kind of said listen i'm not going to let
this uh slow me down at all i'm just
pushing through it but uh
i've got a lot of support around me and
i appreciate everyone's well wishes
means a lot
by the way blake said that you were
trying to get the sympathy vote
was that what's going on yeah i mean
this would this would have been the most
elaborate
uh sympathy vote uh of all time um
so i i think that he's he's as always
being a liar i love that you can you
serve it to me straight
hey um tough week to get hurt because
you're busy with the billboard
uh music awards and getting ready for
that did i mention the weekends
performing
are you hungry like the wolf because i
am duran duran for me too oh the host
yeah i hear they got somebody really
good
how's the prep going and how are you
fighting through that
uh i'm i'm excited you know i've been a
fan of this show for so long and
and obviously been a as a nominee a
presenter multiple times but to be asked
to host
just feels uh you know really special
and and
one of my fellow uh voice coaches kelly
clarkson's been killing it for a couple
of years on the show
i was to be the host on the year where
we're coming back into what feels like
life getting back to
a little version of normal is really
special and and
they've got a great set and kind of take
on how to give it some indoor
outdoor feel with uh vaccinated fans and
it's very exciting
did kelly give you any advice she hasn't
yet but i was going to ask her today
for some advice and of the three coaches
you know
to my right and left i feel like she
would she'd be the the best to set me up
for success whereas the others
you never know you never especially with
blake you never know where he's going do
you
never know exactly he didn't mess with
your bike by the way he's not the one
who messed with your bike
he is not the one well maybe who knows
you never know
all right what are you looking forward
to about hosting the awards because the
lineup is stacked
lineup is stacked um you know i i think
that it's just it's such a great
celebration of
an amazing year in music um so many
incredible artists
and great performances teed up but then
also
you know i don't want to give anything
away but i've got a few surprises up my
sleeve
might be uh jumping up there myself with
two other guys
maybe my brother hey is this um injury
going to mess up your wardrobe changes
because anytime you host the big awards
show you have to change your wardrobe
multiple times no i should i should be
just fine i'm going to i'm going to come
with the fits
uh regardless of the injury
regardless of the injury you'll be good
um is there anything exciting that
you've seen in rehearsals that we need
to know about
uh there's always exciting things i mean
obviously you can just look at the
lineup between
bts uh the weeknd um
you know pink receiving one of our
biggest awards that night in duran duran
uh all people i've been fans of for a
long time to actually get to
to be up there as a host to this show
and and get to celebrate
just such such a great year of music
will be will be incredible so i think
i'm kind of looking at myself as a fan
and the host in a way which is i think
how it should be
any chance we could see your wife pop up
she can
um she's been back and forth to the uk
shooting uh
a new show there which is gonna be
incredible um but hopefully
fingers crossed she can she can come and
support possibly
possibly we'll see i don't know i mean i
i don't have a solid answer one way or
the other yet
your brothers they come in and um
working together now what's the dynamic
how's the dynamic changed
because you are all married how
different is it
it's definitely different but i think
it's just gotten better uh yeah you know
healthier in a way i think we were
we're all so much a part of each other's
lives outside of the work that we did
which is just natural for family
but to to be able to to kind of go home
to separate lives
where you can you know kind of just work
through different things on your own
with your person
and kind of have your own set up within
your family set up
is so important and it just makes all of
us i think
better men better musicians and artists
and and and
honestly better brothers to each other
yeah yeah perfect um
go find out where blake was when you got
injured to make sure that he wasn't
involved in that because i'm telling you
good point it's a very good point
you